- Life is too important
to waste your life.
He say's when fight I fight to win.
To get past it it, you got go through it.
That's true in so many areas,
but it's particularly true with failure.
The way you think effects the way you feel
and the way you feel
effects the way you behave.
If you want to change the
way you act you start back
here with your thoughts.
No matter what you do somebody's
not going to like you.
You cannot please everybody.
- He's an American Evangelical
Christian pastor and author.
He's the founder and senior
pastor of the Saddleback Church,
the 8th largest church in America.
His book The Purpose Driven
Life has had sales of over
30 million copies, making him a
New York Times bestselling author.
He's Rick Warren and here's my take on his
top 10 rules of success.
And as always guys as you're
watching the videos if
you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down in
the comments below and put
quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well.
Also as you are writing
someone down it's much more
likely to stick in your head too, enjoy.
(inspiring music)
- I'm not just playing around,
I'm not just beating the air.
I'm not shadowboxing,
I'm not just goofing off.
Life is too important to waste your life.
He say's when I fight, I fight to win.
I want to win my marriage, I
want to win in my finances,
I want to win in my career.
I want to win in my
spiritual growth, I want to
win in my character, I don't
fight to place I fight to win.
You see every time you make a decision,
what we're talking about here
is clarifying your values.
Every single time you make
a decision you are basing
it on unspoken values.
You have a grid in your mind,
you've never even thought
about this most likely but
you have a set of values
in your mind and every
time you make a decision,
I'm going to do this and not do that.
I'm going to buy this and not buy that.
I'm spend my time and
effort and energy on this
and not on that, you are
showing your hidden values.
The problem is most people
never figured out what they are,
where they came from and
whether they're valued of not.
So really the secret of success
is clarifying your values,
this is a skill you need to learn.
What is valuable to me
and what is not valuable,
every time you make a decision
you reveal your values.
My question is, do you know
where your values came from?
How are they working out?
Is your life working
out with those values?
Do you know where you picked 'em up,
are they working for you?
Your values in life determine your stress,
determine your success and
determine your salvation.
Now you may not realize
this but your values
could be causing stress in your life.
Unclear values cause confusion,
they cause confusion in your life.
Conflicting values in
your life cause tension.
Unclear cause confusion,
conflicting values cause tension.
False values create deception
and the wrong values create disfunction.
There's not a single guy
whose ever learned how
to play football by
reading a manual on it.
Not one, let's just go
out and start throwing
me some passes, let's go
out and shoot some hoops.
Let's go out and play catch.
Let's go out and drive some golf balls.
You learn by doing.
And when there's a problem
in your car say let me
get under the hood here,
I'll figure it out.
You know here's the
carburetor and all of it,
no no, I don't need a
manual, what do you think,
I'm a man, let me just
play around here okay.
Or you say you know I've got
50 wires coming into this
audio system and I need to
figure out how to do it.
I don't need a manual, I'll
just play around with it.
I'll figure out how to install this app,
I'll figure out how to
boot up this computer.
And you just do it by doing it.
You learn by doing.
You don't make excuses for
the failure, you grieve it.
You feel the pain.
You don't brush it off,
you don't down play it.
You feel the pain and you
don't rush to feel better.
Now listen this is the
principal I'm about to tell you.
To get past it you got to get through it,
that's true in so many
areas but it's particularly
true with failure.
To get past your failure,
that failure in your life,
you got to go through it.
You can't go around your failure,
you can't go over your failure,
you can't go under your failure,
you can't ignore your failure.
You need to grieve the failure.
You need to feel the pain.
Now we don't like feeling bad
but grief is a good thing.
Grief is the way we
get through the failure
and grief is the way we learn the lessons.
So often we want to just,
when we fail, we want to just
forget it, push it
aside, stuff our emotions
and then immediately go to the next thing.
When you stuff your emotions,
when you swallow your
emotions your stomach keeps score.
It's kind of like, what
if you took a can of Coke
and you shook it up for a long time
and then you put it in the freezer?
What's going to happen to it?
It's going to explode eventually.
It's going to come out sideways
and this happens in your life
when you don't deal with
your emotions properly.
This is why sometimes six
months after a failure
a marriage falls apart.
Or six months after
somebody gets laid off work
there's another problem, there's
a physical health problem,
things like this because
you've shaken up the can
and you've got all these
emotions feeling inside,
of shame and regret
and fear and insecurity
and all the things that come with failure
and you're not dealing with 'em.
And so you shake it up and so
we're just going to put this
in the refrigerator and
just try to forget about it
and we're going to freeze
it and it's going to explode
and it's going to come out sideways,
in an affair or in a wrong
behavior or an impulsivity
or an addiction or all
kinds of other things.
I've seen this thousands
of times in peoples lives.
You don't minimize it, you don't
rush to feel better, to get
past your failure you've got
to go through the failure.
Examine your own conduct.
What you do is you look and you say,
"What was I good at each stage in my life
"and what did I enjoy doing
at each stage in my life?"
Here are the two things,
I'm good at it and I enjoy doing it.
Now there's some things that you're good
and you don't enjoy, don't
worry 'about that okay.
And there's some things
by the way that you enjoy
and you're not good at.
Many of you don't know
that before I was a pastor
I was a worship leader,
I played guitar and drums
all my life, had garage bands
all the time growing up,
junior high, high school
and college and I actually
started off leading worship
because I have a passion
and I love to sing.
The only problem was nobody
liked to listen to it.
So I love to do it but
I wasn't good at it.
And I didn't have the skills for that.
So the key thing is to say,
"What am I good at and what
"do I love to do?" and I
want you to look for patterns
in your life because if
you were good at it at an
early age you're going to be
good at it later on in life.
A kid whose good as a soccer
player at 10 is going to
be a good and even better
soccer player at 20.
When you learn what it
really means to be gentle
the world's yours, I mean it's your apple.
You're in charge, it's not
driving you you're driving it.
Now in our hard driving,
ego driven, market driven
culture you don't hear a
whole lot about gentleness.
And the reason why is we don't understand
what it really means to be gentle.
We think gentleness means weakness
and God say's absolutely not,
the gentle are the strongest
people on the planet and
the earth with be there's.
It's the weak people who
are arrogant, it's the weak
people who are prideful,
it's the weak people who
are pushy and rude and mean and gossip.
Those are weak people, he
said the truly strong people
in life are the gentle
and world will be there's.
Now I take Monday off,
Monday is my Sabbath.
I don't like taking Monday
off because I don't like
feeling that bad on my day off.
But I find that I need to
to recharge and on Mondays
I am dead to the world.
I do not take calls, I do not read email,
I do not take text messages.
I sleep in, I get up, I
play around the house,
I go to lunch with my wife,
we relax in the afternoon
and Monday evenings we due
family night with our families,
I now have grandkids that are involved.
And we've kept that
religiously, we've kept that
faithfully over the years
and it has kept me from
burning out under enormous pressure.
How would you like to
pastor church where you move
the church building 79
times in the first 13 years?
I did.
Because land was so expensive
we used 79 different
facilities in the first 13 years.
Some weeks I'd be in
five different buildings.
Laguna Hills High School
for Sunday morning,
El Toro High School Sunday evening,
a bank building for Wednesday,
another on on Thursday,
a Saturday night service at
another school and on and on.
We said we're the church
if you can figure out where
we are this week you get to come.
We said we only want our church for really
intelligent people so we
keep changing the location.
But that was a lot of
frustration and I can tell you
I have learned to handle
enormous amounts of stress
and enormous amounts of tension.
But I could not do it if
I didn't rest my body,
if I didn't take my day off, if I didn't
and don't call it your day
off, call it your Sabbath.
Call it your day off you'll
fill it with your Honey Do List.
All that stuff I couldn't
get done you try to use
it to catch up on other
stuff, no it is a day of rest,
relaxation, relationships,
restoration emotionally.
So you need to rest your body.
So forget what can't be changed
and focus on the future.
Until you learn to do
this you're going to be
unhappy much of your life.
Because you hold onto the
habits, you hold onto the hurts
and the hang ups and
you hold onto the grief
and the guilt and the grudges
and that causes so much
unhappiness in your life.
You got to let it go.
Are you focusing all your energies?
You have a limited amount of energy,
you don't have unlimited
energy, you know that,
that's why you get tired,
that's why you get fatigued,
why you get worn out.
You don't have unlimited energy.
Since you don't have unlimited energy
I highly suggest you
don't waste any of it on
something you can't change in the past.
Why in the world would
you give one more second
of emotional energy to something
that is never going to change?
It's done, it's over, it's
finished, your past is past.
You got to let it go, don't waste it.
Your consciousness is the
way you talk to yourself.
- Oh good.
- Your consciousness is the
story you tell yourself.
Remember when I was talking
earlier about autopilot?
- Yes.
- I can tell you your autopilot.
Finish this sentence 10 times,
"It's just like me to be." and
I'll tell you your autopilot.
It's just like me to be lazy.
It's just like me to be late.
It's just like me, that is your autopilot.
Now the story we tell
ourselves is the fourth factor
that influences us, the Bible say's
"As a man thinks in his heart."
- "So he is."
- So he is and and so you
have to change your autopilot.
Now let me tell you how to do this.
All of us have things we
want to change in our lives.
The way you think effects the way you feel
and the way you feel
effects the way you behave.
If you want to change the way you act
you start back here with your thoughts.
If I'm acting depressed it's
because I feel depressed
and if I feel depressed
it's because I'm choosing
to think depressed thoughts.
You can't change a feeling
but you can change a thought.
You tell a little kid, be happy!
I'm trying Daddy.
You can't force a feeling
okay, you can't force a feeling
but you can change the thought
that is creating the feeling.
Now here's a real important
thing about temptation
and I've shared this with a lot of people,
it's helped a lot of people.
When you have a habit or I
have a habit that I don't like
and I'm being tempted to go
to this habit over and over
and over, the key to changing
a habit is not to resist it
but to replace it.
Not to resist but refocus.
If a guy's having problem
with pornography and he's
watching TV he doesn't just say,
"No I don't want this, I don't want this."
He just flips the channel.
The moment you change the
channel the temptation loses
it's power on you.
Do not listen, here's a
pastor telling you this,
do not resist temptation.
- Do not resist temptation!
- Let me tell you why
- Say's the pastor!
- Yeah let me tell you why.
What you resist persists.
Because the whole time
you're focused on it.
What you need to do is
just change your focus
and this is taking your
conscious and saying
I'm going to renew my mind, I'm
going to think on these things.
What sort of things are pure and lovely
and a good report, I'm going
to think about good things.
- And that's how to be
transformed by the renewing.
- By the renewing of your mind.
When I was a little kid
Oprah my mom would bake
chocolate chip cookies
at night and I'd walk and
stand up at the kitchen
table and my mom would say,
"Now Ricky, don't you eat
those chocolate chip cookies
"cause dinners comin'."
And I'd say, "I'm not
mom I'm just lookin'."
(audience laughs)
Whatever gets your attention gets you.
So if you want to break
a habit you just refocus
and that's the renewing of your mind.
Put your mind on the right thing.
No matter what you do somebody's
not going to like you.
You cannot please everybody.
You can't please everybody all the time
or even part of the time.
So heres the thing I would say to you.
You don't need other peoples
approval to be happy.
Now that's an important
thing, we think if I can just
get everybody to love me I'll be happy.
No first you're never going to do it.
And if like, some of
you've been trying to get
your parents approval
and they're like dead
or they're elderly and if
you haven't got it by now
you're not going to get it.
But here's the thing, you don't need it.
You don't need anybody
else's approval to be happy.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Erik Coleman asked me to
so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want
me to profile next leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love what did
you learn from Rick today
that had the biggest impact on you.
What lesson did you
really absorb that you're
going to immediately apply to your life
or business somehow?
Please leave it down in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Judy.
Judy thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, I really
appreciate your support and
that picture that you
posted on Instagram as well,
thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you so much.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love I'll see you soon.
- Knowing how to
recognize what's important
and what's not important.
I can't tell you how
important this skill is
and how few people have it.
To look at a situation and go
that's important that's not.
That matters, that doesn't matter.
That's valuable, that's not valuable.
This is crucial, that's not crucial.
Leaders know what's important
and they focus on that
and they forget everything else.
Successful people know what
matters and don't worry
about what doesn't matter.
Paul say's this one thing I do,
not these 40 things I dabble in.
He is focused, he is laser focused.
And you have to learn this skill in life
to be successful at work
and at home and in life.
The skill of knowing what matters most.
- I've always been taunted
about my skin tone and the
brown spots on my face, which
has made me very insecure.
As an adult I discovered make
up, I never let my family
or friends or anyone I'm
dating see me without makeup.
So to be here without it
right now is a huge step.
- The fact is everybody's
got flaws, nobody's perfect
but the definition is
flaw is 100% subjective.
Because what we might think
is a flaw in our culture
is a beauty mark in
somebody else's and so.
- Yes there's an African
country where the fatter
you are the more husbands you get.
- I'm going there!
(audience applauds and cheers)
Alright.
- Now.
- Okay.
- You know I bought a pair
of jeans the other day
and I got home and it was
distressed jeans, there was
a little tag on it and it said,
"These jeans are intentionally
flawed to make them unique."
- Wow.
- You need to write that one down.
We are all intentionally
flawed to make us unique.
Now Portia's problem is
actually a deeper problem
and the issue here is it
is the myth that being
beautiful will make me happy.
I live in Southern
California, there are a lot of
pretty people there who are miserable.
So it is not an automatic,
beauty equals happiness.
Happiness is a choice.
So you got to realize that
sometimes your own self
rejection is turning people away.
- Everybody went "Hmm."
Yes it's her perception of what the.
- Absolutely.
- Yes.
- She's flat out gorgeous
but the point is is that
it becomes a self fulfilling prophecy.
I say this to Portia though,
you don't want friends
who only love you for your looks
(audience applauds)
And you don't want a
husband who only loves
you for your looks.
(audience applauds)
- [Oprah] It's the truth.
- I'll tell you this, our
looks aren't going to stay.
Now mine do but I don't know about yours.